The real beauty of the system is that
you can use it with string keys too.
You just need to come up with some hash
function that converts letters into
numbers.
Individual letters can be pretty
easily converted into ASCII values and
many languages already have
functions built in that do that.
We can combine the ASCII values with
a formula to get a unique hash for
each letter.
So what should our hash
function look like?
Again, there are some trade-offs here.
Do we want every word
in it's own bucket?
Are you okay with collisions but
want a relatively simple hash function?
If you have 30 or less words, you can
probably just use the ASCII value for
the first letter of
a string as a hash value.
The standard hash code function for
string keys in Java a large hash
table over having any collisions.
The formula looks something like this.
For example, let's say,
we're going to hash the word UDACITY and
we're starting with the first
two letters of the string, UD.
We can plug these ASCII
values into the equation to
get a hash value that is
unique to our string.
Why does this work?
Well by multiplying the ASCII value for
each letter by a power of some number
like 31, we can guarantee that
every number representation or
hash value will be
unique to that string.
A hash function like
that would be great for
a dictionary where we need
unique buckets for each string.
However strings with just three or four
letters already have huge hash values.
The tradeoff is really important here.
As long as you have the space for it, a
unique hash value can be really useful.
Lastly, why is the number 31 used here?
The earliest hash functions took
advantage of some properties of
the number 31 and research showed
that it was a great choice for
this kind of string hashing.
However, now there are more complex hash
functions that have been discovered.
So thirty one is more of a convention
than the best value for every situation.
Remember that designing a solution for
your keys is the most important thing.
Don't get too bogged down in
all of these conventions.